aquí en tel aviv la marcha del orgullo
se desarrolla primero que todo bajo un
intenso calor y también con el regreso
de los eventos masivos algo que no había
sido posible en los últimos dos años es
debido en 2020 a la cancelación por la
pandemia y en 2021 que se desarrolló una
edición reducida decenas de miles de
personas se han acercado aquí en un
desfile que recorrió uno de los
principales bulevares de las afueras del
centro de la vida y termina en un parque
público una postal distinta a la
habitual habitualmente el desfile suele
terminar en las orillas del mediterráneo
pero por diversas obras que hay en tel
aviv terminó trasladándose aquí al pub
al parque hayarkón s como decía el
regreso de un evento masivo y también el
pistoletazo de salida para lo que serán
los principales marchas las principales
marchas del orgullo gay en toda europa o
sea también le pregunto cuál es el
panorama de la violencia contra la
comunidad el eje benito el eje de lg gt
y más en israel perdón
y si tomamos en cuenta que se encuentra
medio oriente israel tiene varios
avances en relación a sus países vecinos
en derechos de la comunidad el jefe te
disculpas pero las agresiones son
habituales y en 2021 el último informe
que se conoce se registraron más de
2.900 agresiones o casos de fobia contra
esta comunidad un crecimiento del 10 por
ciento respecto de 2020 y
particularmente en la zona de tel aviv-
la regional central se registró la mayor
cantidad de estas denuncias lo cual
puede entenderse de dos maneras por un
lado es que esta ciudad que
habitualmente es vista como gayfriendly
no es no está tampoco exenta de los
hechos de violencia pero a la vez es que
existen más mecanismos para denunciar
que en otras ciudades es como en
jerusalén donde los hechos de violencia
se registran se reportan en menor
cantidad pero también existe un gran
conservadurismo y una gran presencia de
la religión que termina generando
distintos tipos de agresiones contra la
comunidad